pierre martinet ex agent de la direction
générale des services extérieurs et
fondateur de whincup security defence
pierre martinet bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france 16 agents écarté des
services de renseignement comment est-ce
que vous accueillez cette annonce d'hier
c'est une bonne chose mais c'est assez
inquiétant parce que 16 vous cacher
c'est peut-être l'art qui cache la forêt
parce que 16 personnes qui sont aux
liens avec cet islamisme dans les
services de renseignement c'est
théoriquement des services qui sont
protégés et qu'ils sont très comme
dirait je t'écris blé avant d'être
renseigné avant d'y rentrer de pouvoir y
rentrer et je suis assez inquiet
justement je suis assez inquiet de
savoir qu'il y a eu autant de personnes
écartées des services de renseignement
sécurité intérieure je crois est ce
qu'il veut c'est à dire c'est que pour
moi le terme radicalisation n'est pas
approprié à tout ça c'est pour moi c'est
plutôt de parler d' adhésion au projet
islamiste et cette adhésion projet
samistes on peut la retrouver dans
n'importe quel service est aussi bien
dans les services de renseignements
intérieurs comme peut-être extérieur et
dans les rangs armés dans les forces de
l'ordre et dans tout l'est dans certains
services publics on le sait déjà depuis
très longtemps
justement est ce qu'on peut parler de
deux mouvances l'infiltration de la dgs
idée dgs de divers services de
renseignement de
les personnes radicaliser c'est un
phénomène que l'on peut vraiment
contrôler alors le contrôle c'est
difficile parce que aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'elle craint une radicalisation où
il ya aucun on essaye de est celle d'un
jolivet ce terme radicalisation et
mettre des conditions à la réalisation
des thermes
mais pour moi c'est pas foncièrement
c'est une erreur dès le départ on a
occulté l'idéologie qui a eu qui a vu
qu'il y avait autour de ces attentats
islamistes depuis on va dire depuis 2012
mais il y en a eu avant aussi et on n'a
pas voulu voir que la société française
était déjà imprégné est infiltré par
cette idéologie là alors aussi bien par
les frères musulmans qu'on trouve à
n'importe quel strates de la société un
des médecins des avocats juste radical
et peut-être pourquoi pas un juge aussi
un jour et il ya aussi la halle à
l'idéologie et la mouvance salafiste qui
on retrouve quand on retrouve dans toute
la société française et on la retrouve
dans toute la société française donc on
en trouve aussi dans les services
publics est toujours refusé de voir
jusqu'à présent c'est que c'est s'aider
des individus qui adhèrent au projet de
loi islamique qui a commencé en 1928 et
aujourd'hui on essaye de traiter un mal
c'est déjà bien de s'en rendre compte
mais on commence vraiment maintenant à
nous mais l'aîné est nommé cette
idéologie mais on va toujours pas essayé
de lutter contre ces logiques pour
lutter contre sa théologie il faudrait
déjà mettre en exergue les deux deux
mouvances mes frères musulmans est
l'épée le salafisme qui amènent des
personnels de service de sécurité
intérieur des services des
renseignements avérés à ces mouvances et
certaines personnes sont capables de
passer à l'acte parce que dans dans
l'idéologie globale et dans le projet de
val
il ya aussi il y à aussi bien les
le prosélytisme et des revendications
religieuses du quotidien que les
personnes qui vont essayer d'imposer
cette vision par des actes violents
pourtant le gouvernement annonce de
nouvelles mesures pour contrôler et
l'habilitation des agents quelles
sont-elles exactement et si elles ne
sont pas suffisantes
qu'est ce que vous vous proposez il
serait quand même c'est quand même c'est
quand même la moindre des choses qu'on
puisse renforcer les mesures pour
accorder les habilitations au secret ou
secret défense à des personnes et des
personnels qui font partie des services
de renseignements intérieurs passer la
moindre des choses moi j'ai quand j'ai
postulé pour le service action de la
dgse
on avait on a au moins un homme en quête
avant de pouvoir intégrer ce service qui
était à l'époque fait par la vsd la drs
dès aujourd'hui les renseignements
militaires
et si certaines personnes avaient à
l'époque je me souviens certaines
personnes avait de la famille en algérie
n'a pas proche des réseaux qui pouvaient
subir des pressions ces personnes-là été
écartée aujourd'hui je pense que le
phénomène de radicalisation et
islamistes au sens large du terme lisent
cette idéologie là à dépasser largement
les gouvernements successifs jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et on arrive à traiter
militairement
on arrive à traiter actuellement
certaines actions où certains et
certaines personnes radicaliser en un
mot les stopper en revanche on ne fait
toujours rien pour essayer de stopper la
réelle cause de ce phénomène là c'est à
dire l'idéologie islamiste
le projet islamiste au refus de voir que
en 1928 les frères musulmans qui ont été
créés pour pour ça et en 2020 en 2020
nous avons effectivement des attentats
nous avons effectivement des français
qui combattent islamisme et les réseaux
terroristes islamistes à l'étranger en
revanche en europe
en france on ne fait absolument rien
pour essayer de stopper vidéo le gist
habitants qu'on ne va pas stopper
l'idéologie islamiste c'est à dire
l'acte la cause de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france on aura toujours
des personnes qui vont adorer ce projet
aura toujours des personnes qui
passeront à l'acte et ton tour
pour compléter votre question il est
grand temps que les services qui sont
censés lutter contre ce terrorisme la
soupe le terrorisme islamiste soient
totalement membrez clean et totalement
ou renseigner avant avant d'intégrer
qu'il a personnellement fait dans le
tarn ça nous aurait pu être évité le
montage de la tente a des avantages du
service de renseignement intérieur qui a
eu lieu il ya eu quatre personnes
assassinées
alors maintenant il faut trouver des
solutions encore plus sombre merci merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions pierre
martinez rappelle que vous êtes ex agent
de la dgse et fondateur de wincor
security défense